like if a guy is into you so soon and
he's like all in like right away we
don't we're like why we're like what's
going on here you already know hold the
[ __ ] up
what's going on where are you putting an
effort into conversation yeah i think
it's women generally like we were
talking about women generally they don't
even want it
generally
they want a guy who's got options
i know that's why they don't want a guy
who ain't got no women
you don't think so no no i i'm i'm
saying for me personally yeah um i mean
i want an attractive dude
you're an attractive dude will come with
women that if you if you think a guy's
attractive there are other women right
you don't you want a guy that no one
else wants no no
you don't want no regular old dude
yeah explain to myself yeah
you don't women generally don't want a
guy who's not attractive to other women
they want a guy who was attractive to
other women but they feel like they got
it yeah yeah
right
you never got him i got him do you think
that's the same for men
which guys what is that the same for men
vice versa
um
as a guy
as a guy he wants a woman who's
attractive
but he wants a woman it's kind of yeah
he wants a woman who's attractive
but
he doesn't want a woman who's been for
the streets if that makes sense
does that make sense like he wants a
woman who maybe knows a little thing
maybe knows a little bit
a little bit like a little bit but you
know a guy wants a guy wants a woman
that he can mold
no
let aline go shoes next sorry i didn't
go so what i have heard is that you know
what you have heard
what had happened was
excuse me you're excused but going
i'm sorry let me say let me
excuse you
um so what i have heard right go on is
you know like you know men like the same
thing as what we just described except
you know they want the woman to be you
know innocent
you know like
oh like i just want one person i just
want this like just basically just
wanting one man basically never having
had like not never having sex but just
like in it more innocent yeah
more innocent
not not a whole basically being
experienced yet not having any type of
experience so can you explain that to me
um
so
okay so a guy wants a woman who has
maybe
excuse me who has maybe had experience
yes
intrigued other guys
like to want them yeah but she hasn't
gone there yeah if that makes sense
because a guy
wants a woman who's attractive mm-hmm
right that other guy
that is in demand but she doesn't he
doesn't want to know that she's been
all of those guys in fact do you know i
mean
do you feel like those girls
like
exist like they're common yeah probably
not in these days yeah okay because i've
always heard that like in all the like
dating channels they're like they don't
want a girl that's too hot because if
she's too hot like there's no there's no
way do you know
what i say to men i would say
men don't understand the value in
i don't want to be like go ahead i don't
want to be like why yeah
i don't want to hey
men don't understand the value in the um
mediocre looking woman
who has values
does that make sense
like
men have
gone in these days and times they've
gone for the most
instagram model 10 number 10 she's got
breasts she's got ass she's got all of
this kind of stuff right
but they have they have
negated the
quote-unquote
six
on the scale right he has good values
and that is the woman that is going to
be your long-term partner you know the
woman that is 10 10
10 out of 10 that every man's looking at
and she knows every man is looking at
her right
he's thinking oh this guy's in my inbox
this guy's in my dms this guy's in
that is not the woman that you want to
go for as a long-term partner
it's the woman that we're good to look
at
and women don't understand that
guys will see that woman
and like her picture
but the 10 10 instagram model
like the picture you don't think
anything but
he ain't trying to take that woman for
his wife
he's trying to take the woman oh yeah
there's a difference between yeah
attractive there's that has good morals
well there's no i mean like that's
that's the type of guy there's a
difference between like sexual attention
and relationship attention i understand
that did you have something you wanted
to add eileen i feel like you're getting
kind of frustrated
no your body language is arms crossed i
know that's just that's just how i like
she's getting cut off a lot sorry
yeah i'm just not very much of a vocal
person i feel like but um vocalize
um once you
[ __ ] you're saying so i can't i don't
remember because you were saying
something and they just had something on
the top of my head it was it was it was
it about he was saying that like like
men value purity more
like yeah
yeah like they they want something like
that they want a girl that hasn't slept
with like too many guys basically yes so
like but you guys want women that have
the experience yet you still want that
purity
so where is that that doesn't make sense
exactly that's not going to be i agree
with you it doesn't make sense yeah you
can't
you can't have a pure woman that hasn't
experienced anything that doesn't make
sense why does someone that expect has
had experience make them not pure
like what defines purity in your eyes
i define that for me as me as an
individual me as me as me yeah you um
i don't look at i don't look at people
in that type of i don't look at me as
pure i'm talking about it
as an individual well it's like it's
it's genetics like they're biologically
predispositioned to want a woman that's
pure because they want to ensure
paternity so so biologically like it's
the same way like we want a guy that
makes more money than us because before
we needed a guy that was more competent
than us to take care of us and like who
wants to be with a guy that you're more
competent than like that's not you want
to feel protected yeah yeah and that's
like like like that would be like men
calling us gold diggers it's like us
like saying to them oh it's wrong for
you wanting a pure girl like they're
biologically wired to want that
you know no question like can most guys
get it which is why back in the day yeah
chastity and purity was
you know it was um it was it was a thing
a woman who was a virgin was a thing
wait i have a question would you would
you date a girl that was a virgin and
like wait until you were married with
her would you want to i would that's
what i've noticed but okay so yeah
you are one of them
you're 40 years old i'm 48
many people she slept yeah
if you were
single and like what 20 something would
you would you wait
like would you have sex with somebody
yes
probably if i was like in my 20s yes
because now
now i've experienced more the world you
know i mean i'm like do you know what
i've noticed